you
hi everyone's Gerry I'm on tactics
trainer chess comm I'm gonna try three
more puzzles here this one it's black to
playing and I'll just be sharing my
train of thought with each of these so
let's see hmm
this night I'm not afraid of he won't be
in contribute won't be contributing in
this puzzle
there's back rank issues for white no
flight square this rook is unprotected
so too is this Queen hmm there are also
maybe some ideas of if this pawn ever
captures the rook come over here and
give checkmate since G 1 square is
controlled so I'm pointing out a lot of
rough thoughts that I have with this
position now I'm really trying to tie it
all together and come up with something
decent this bishop is hit twice huh can
you really do without moving this bishop
or let's see this pawn is also maybe I
could view this pawn as being
unprotected all right it's attacked once
defended once this Knight probably won't
be contributing much either so it's kind
of like a queen rook and Bishop versus a
queen and rook situation back rank
vulnerabilities g1 is covered this pot
ever makes a capture can I mean can I
force this pawn to capture in some way
like if Queen here if pawn takes it's me
but what is that really doing Queen here
you take the bishop or do you oh hang on
I just find the solution no no no no
it's not that easy Queen here you're
threatening the rook and if the rook
takes here then you're gonna you bring
the rough down like so and give
checkmate Queen here is that really it
there's got to be an easy way to defend
though isn't there what if the ruck just
moves or if the ruck just moves um I
don't know f1 if Queen here rook to f1
there's no good there's no good checking
move
I'm good forcing move Queen takes here
doesn't amount to anything
so Queen to g3 is actually my first
thought Queen takes you take the Queen
and then back rank stuff and what is the
other threat like if Queen here suppose
the Queen goes to e to the Queen goes to
e2 queen g3 should there be another move
I'm considering I think this is a key
move because you want to be in a
position to maybe take on e3 if one of
the major pieces takes if the Queen of
rook takes the bishop you also want to
put pressure on the rook threaten some
Mane to take the rook and then after a
block you take the Queen you also want
to maybe put pressure on h2 after
because you could have a follow up of
rook h5 which I which is going to
threaten or induce h3 and then there
could be some sacrifice on this square
with maybe mate following up Queen to h3
stuff so if Queen g3 rook f1 Queen h v
h3 rook takes h3 pawn takes Queen takes
h3 and that's me so Queen g3
okay well Queens III if rook f1 I
believe I know what I'm doing with this
move yeah
Queen g3 rook f1 rook h5 is going to end
up winning
however Queen g3 Queen e2 to defend the
rook and also the h2 square indirectly
oh oh hang on if Queen g3 Queen e2 the
Queen is now a defender of the rook
maybe there's a way you can chase away
the Queen actually I was just ready to
suggest Queen g3 Queen e2 rook here but
then then you take the black Queen
because the rook isn't there to give
checkmate so Queen g3 Queen to e2 I'm
stuck at that point the other thing
Queen to e2 would be doing is in some
lines defending h5 directly actually
that's what it would be doing Queen 2 G
3 Queen to e2 you're defending this rook
from coming over huh I feel like this
should be it but I don't know what's the
follow up Queen g3 if the Queen plays
here oh you still come over okay let's
run with the Queen g3 of Queen here you
come over because if Queen takes rook
you take the rook and that's mate on the
spot so Queen g3 of Queen e2 Queen H
let's try this again Queen g3 Queen e2
rook h5 you're threatening made on h2 h3
and then I really want to smash that
pawn up
I just take that pawn rook takes pawn
paan takes it would be the only move
Queen takes pawn check the Queen would
slide over to defend but I'm not seeing
a good follow up from there you could
give a check but the clink of lock here
you could then give a check here but the
Queen still comes over and blocks all
these checks on h2 or or g2 but maybe
maybe that's um maybe maybe oh maybe the
solution of this is that there isn't to
win since white is down material maybe
going for some perpetual but I think
there would actually be something better
after Queen g3 Queen e2 rook age 5 h3
maybe you play Bishop to f4 threatening
made on h2 and the King has to run to g1
and then and then I believe you take on
each three cuz the pawn on g2 would be
pinned and then the threat would be rook
to h1 check giving up the rook followed
by Queen h2 mate I'm just gonna go with
that I spend enough time on this one
Queen g3 it is correct let's see what
line the computer goes with it's going
with that one
rook h5 is the follow-up and after h3 I
believe this is where I need to pause
for a moment okay I really want to do
this but I think that there's a way to
win there's got to be with these
weakened dark squares Bishop f4
threatens and matin one I was just ready
to abandon this idea Bishop f4 I was
thinking Queen here offering a queen
trade but you could take the Queen this
pawn is pinned Bishop f4 King here rook
takes pawn the pawn is pinned in the
threat is rook H 1 followed by Queen h2
it can't be stopped that is the correct
move take here and it is solved the big
threat here at this point is rook h1
forcing the king in the corner queen h2
mate
alright let's just dive into the next
one problem two of three all right
there's not gonna be very many choices
with this one okay hang on for a second
queen is attacked queen is attacked
white is down a lot of material a full
rook okay I think I see the solution of
this one
this one maybe isn't too bad let's see
very limited choices right I think the
trick here is to not take with the pond
and the reason I say that is because I
think you want to have your queen and
have your queen in a position where she
could give check on h5 something with
that move and the Knight to e2 move is
what I'm it's what I have in mind here
so you take with the bishop you're now
threatening the Queen and if she goes
here let's say the follow up would be
queen h5 check King in the corner our
King G 1 and then nightie 2 and the
Queen would have to give itself up for
the night so I believe that this is the
first move Queen takes Bishop the Queen
can go somewhere else on this diagonal
there's only one other safe square that
would watch over the Queen from getting
to this h5 square so Queen takes Bishop
Queen here well you could move the
Bishop to g4 attack the Queen and then I
don't believe there's going to be a way
to stop Queen here hang on Queen takes
Bishop Queen to f3
and then what queen takes bishop queen
to f3 oh you would give this check first
yeah there's a there's an important move
order trick here Queen takes Bishop
Queen f3 if you but move the Bishop to
g4
there's Queen g3 and then if you play
the Queen to h5 to give check there's
queen h2 to successfully block the King
wouldn't have to make use of g1 however
after Queen takes Bishop Queen f3 there
is still a way to control eetu only this
time with the Bishop since it could be
playing to g4 with the tempo on the
Queen so you don't necessarily have to
have the Queen getting to this h5
squared control e to the bishop can do
that with tempo with an attack on the
White Queen
so Queen takes Bishop Queen f3 Queen h4
check the Queen can't go here the bishop
watches over h3 Queen takes Bishop Queen
f3 Queen h4 check King g1 Bishop g4
attacking the Queen and then if the
Queen moves there's 92 the Queen has to
give itself up there is maybe one other
trick that white could have Queen takes
Bishop Queen f3 Queen to h4 check King 8
king g1 Bishop g4 you're attacking the
Queen what if there's a counter
attacking move against the queen with g3
I think the Queen would then calmly come
back to h5 and there is still a threat
of Knight to e2 check and Queen to h3
leading to mate I think that's it it is
correct it is going with this and I
believe this is an important move Queen
h4 and then finally Queen or bishop here
that is correct and just throw the
knight in there
alright that was it alright I'm actually
happy with that one
all right let's see if we go three four
three last one here
okay puzzle three all righty let's see
black to play and there's two different
checks you could be throwing in
something tells me it's not going to be
either of those because white could do
great things and by great I mean simply
develop and defend the threat so it's
probably not some check here how's the
material looking it's looking even
there's maybe a slight problem with the
see one square maybe rook c8 it's maybe
uh something oh I think I'm seeing it
now Knight here no let's see I think um
well here's a problem here's a problem
okay there's a potential for concie to I
think that's the this is the key to this
problem this Knight is just two hops
away from jumping into c2 and yeah I am
seeing it I believe there's not a good
way to defend c2 square
I think the first move is hmm let's see
do I really know this yeah I think the
first move is rook here not committing
the knight just yet there is the threat
of night before actually it's doing more
than just threatening to get here be
threatening the Queen directly it be
also threatening just to trap the Queen
like rook c8 if castles night before and
the Queen has no safe squares like night
would be guarding d3
I think if you move the night here first
then there's always a kick you go a a
three and then if rook c8 you take this
rook c1 check I don't believe is too
scary however there is an ensuing check
on e4 I for some reason I don't I don't
really like that this night before I
move first rook c8 it seems that's my
actually that's my first thought these
checks and I am I sure they don't work
pretty sure they don't work rook c8
here's another thing I thought about if
white tries to maybe defend c2 with
Knight a three rook c8 if Knight a three
and then there's this check because the
Knights I'm protected on that Square
that's one thing I say to myself if I'm
considering certain candidate moves by
my opponent if they make a move and it's
going to non-protected squares their way
to exploit that and there would be in
this case rook c8 Knight 83 check the
knight is dead rook c8 and what are you
going to do with the Queen it's got to
be pretty scary
oh here's the other one mmm if looked to
see eight and then well I'm actually a
bit stumped too no rook seed rook c8 a
three what if a three is still played I
was saying night before a three but what
if rook c8 a three now if the knight
moves somewhere the Queen could maybe be
making use of this square hmm you know
what it might be it might actually be
something to do with this Knight e4 move
it might have to do with the rook
getting to the C 1 square came here and
then Knight e4 check it's gotta be
something pawn check spent four minutes
on this seems like such a quiet position
but there must be something mmm
night before eighth free
yeah it's I don't know I just don't know
rook c8 a three Night Moves oh oh I'm
seeing it I think this is the correct
move rook c8 if a three-night a 5a
double attack against the Queen Queen to
b4 Knight takes b3 maybe right away or
after a queen capture I think right away
you're attacking the rook and you're
covering d2 which is then threatening
rook to c1 checkmate I'm gonna go with
that it is correct
oh and they're not going with this a
three line maybe I could show it after
the puzzle but I believe I have it now
just throw the knight into this square
night here night c2 next that is correct
that was the that was the big trick with
this one night c2 and that's it the
problem solved but let me go back and
bring up this analysis board right about
here and let's go down okay this is the
line I was wondering about let me just
see what it has to say about after rook
c8 does it suggest a three a three
Knight a5 Queen to b4 Knight takes b3 I
was correct because of the main threat
let me show this is the line I was
wondering about rook c8 Oh this was the
move initially and then black Tim
Holbrook c8 if a three-night a5 Queen B
for Knight takes b3 and if Queen takes
this is me there's that line that needed
to be understood
for this puzzle I believe all right
it's uh I think one of the few times
that I've gone three for three
feel free to share how you did with
these puzzles and I'll catch you in the
next video take care bye
you